I'm allowed to go in the ocean again in
a week
and so I'm gonna take that board you're
gonna take me out yeah
it's time it's summer if anyone
approaches you and anyone's like Cody
what the act like you have no clue
yeah yeah you're bored you're bored man
whose face is that what face
oh I don't know I just
I liked it oh it's really nice you
should get one who is it though the fake
the guy on the no no it's this guy it's
this dude it's your wallpaper who is it
though how do you know him it's just him
it's your car it's rap I know because
he's on my board yeah I know but where
how do you know him in real life well
he's always the guy on my phone
background yeah he was right over there
and as you stand on the other side of
the road
it's the guy from the billboard it just
keeps getting bigger and crazy you see
the billboard coming in who is he though